to have here on this program the author
of the book everybody's talking about
right now and everybody should go get
when it comes out
uh and it is going to be out next month
it is none other than
the uh it's better to be filled with the
name of this book and the author seth
wickersham kind enough to join us right
here on the rich eisen show is one of
his first interviews on his book tour of
the book to be published october 12th
how are you seth wickersham
i'm great man how are you you know
really quick yes it's really interesting
to listen to that interview because
um
you know i know that we'll talk about
some of the more kind of buzzworthy
things about the book but one of my
favorite chapters in the book is
actually
from that exact time when tom brady was
in his mid thirties
you know his fame had exploded he's got
young kids
they had reached this kind of highest
plateau where they just couldn't quite
close it in the super bowl
and
you know he was looking to improve by
percentages of a percentage point things
that only he would see so that they
could get over the top and get back to
winning super bowls and on
it it's just one of my favorite you know
chapters in the book where i i write a
lot about where brady was in his life at
that point and at one point in the book
i was at his apartment and um
we were talking in his living room
and someone walked into the living room
and who would it be alex guerrero and
alex guerrero was you know one of the
key people who helped tom
you know
get that little bit better so that he
could get back to winning super bowls
yeah you're referring to his trainer and
then you're also referring to an
interview we just played uh on our
peacock and sirius xm only segment from
day two of this show being a simulcast
of november 5th 2014 when brady
uh only had uh three super bowl
championships that's it that's all he
had
right and now here he has seven coming
home and then in the middle of the the
homecoming that's coming up uh or his
old home uh returning to where he once
belonged um to use the get back beatles
phrase um
your book uh and the excerpts coming out
so let's get into some of this stuff
right here overall
this book for anyone who knows it's not
just about the the departure it starts
when this book when did you first start
to
uh report on stuff how far back are you
going here in this book seth
yeah i mean i go back to you know bill
belichick's
you know coaching career you know before
he was with the patriots and i go back
to tom brady's you know childhood in in
san mateo and you know my goal with the
book was to try to get at as best as i
could thoroughly and as
accurately and as
best i could
how these two men became so great and
then another part of it was like what
what were the cost of that greatness you
know what were the things that they were
the sacrifices that they make that might
end up lingering longer um because of
what they wanted to achieve and so you
know i i went back as far as i felt like
i needed to to try to
answer those questions as best that they
could well i mean and just for those who
are going to get it and i can't um
i can't endorse it any harder than just
not only having you on the show but just
again starting to read it last night it
just sucked me straight in certainly in
the in the prologue which was the the
night of brady's final game and the the
wild card uh round loss to vrable of all
people in the tennessee titans it's just
uh it it fills in a lot of blanks um
here um and i i want to kind of go on
one by one here
of what we saw yesterday in the espn
piece and pull a little bit out of you
certainly since belichick has already
said it's quote unquote not true
that um that that he called brady or ver
only would get on the phone with brady
to say
farewell at the quarterbacks behest
wanting to meet personally what what
what about that exchange
now i'm happy to talk about that i mean
i appreciate what what coach belichick
said i i stand by what i wrote and
you know the anecdote is really about
tom and you know it's well documented
that the night that he told robert craft
that he was leaving that he spoke to
bill by the phone and he wanted to he
visited robert crafton person he and he
he wanted to visit belichick in person
belichick was just unavailable and there
was no
i don't know why he was unavailable and
so that's why um you know i think it's
more of an anecdote about tom where
you know i think that tom wanted to see
him
but when you look at that decision that
he made and obviously he's making that
decision because of decisions to leave
the patriots because of the decisions
that bill belichick made
um he later told a friend that night
that you know he thought it was telling
of the state of their relationship
um you know that they ended up talking
on the phone good conversation by the
way but that it was in the phone on the
phone and not in person
and so it's entirely possible that
belichick was either out of town or you
know what i'm saying like is it feasible
that there literally was no way for him
to meet brady even though the
sensibility would be if you know you
move things around it's not like he was
sitting there catching up on billions or
something like that you know what i mean
so which is a good show
um
but yeah any but again it was about how
tom sort of took it and what he told one
of his best friends that night um about
about how i did transpired okay um
another uh item that leaps out at me for
sure
um is the fact that um we found out
through your book that malcolm butler
did not play in super bowl 52
because he and matt patricia
um
got into an argument and belichick just
basically said uh that's it you're
you're you're gonna play but
not play i mean what what's this
situation behind all that seth yeah i
mean so obviously you know malcolm
butler um you know benching in that
super bowl has remained a mystery and
you know i did my best to try to look at
what happened and you know i think that
you know after the his his unbelievable
interception against the seahawks
um you know this thing hadn't been quite
right between him in the patriots you
know he
you remember he was late for his first
ota after that and there was a stare
down with belichick in the in the the
nfl pa actually had to intervene and
then you
you know some of the coaches i think
they felt like that butler had gotten a
little bit too big there was a contract
dispute didn't play great against the
falcons in the super bowl
and
you know even butlers admitted that you
know when in the practices he got sick
right before they played the eagles in
the super bowl
and um was hospitalized and then when he
came to practice he's you know he's
publicly admitted that he wasn't like
his locked in
as uh you know he should have been and i
think that
you know the new england coaches can
forgive a lot of sins but you know not
being locked in before super bowl i
think is is one of those that was
unforgivable and
so you know butler and matt patricia
who's a defensive coordinator at the
time you know had a couple heated
exchanges at practice
and um
you know
he he learned that you know he was
essentially see that he was benched in
that you know his time as a patriot was
essentially over and um
at the
uh super at the at the team party after
they lost to the eagles
you know he was deeply hurt and um
you know knew that his time in new
england was over and you know when when
teammates were asking him like what had
happened
you know he he had some choice words and
their words that i can't
repeat on your on your show i know and
they're all in the book um but
any sense as to why belichick still
dressed him i mean
i don't know why he was dressed for the
game i mean obviously that game plan you
know they were having problems on
defense that's well documented and you
know i have some some discussions
between the coaches at halftime about
defensive adjustments that they needed
to make in that game i still don't know
why
you know given the way that they were
getting chewed up on on defense
um
you know why they wouldn't even give him
a look
seth wickersham author of it's better to
be feared here on the rich eisen show
going through some of the bullet points
that we have already learned from his
book um and uh and let's keep going on
for some of these as well uh brady when
you you found out that brady would have
left
a forced away to los angeles had there
been a los angeles team um
yeah i mean you know look he had some
you know in the middle of the dynasty
run
you know there was a there was a which
one called
yeah right i mean i feel like it lasted
20 years but in the middle of it when
they were you know going back to what i
was referring to before they were in
that kind of plateau where they had
plateaued at this incredibly high level
but it was still a plateau and
you know tom had a contentious contract
negotiation during that time and that
was during a time you know he was a
newlywed and he was a young father and
he was spending a lot more time out in
l.a
and you know there are people close to
him who just think that like you know if
there had been a team at that time in
l.a this contract disputed gotten so
contentious that maybe he would have
tried to to force a trade there now
would have ever done that i i don't know
for sure was just what the people
closest to him his family members
speculated and
um you know you know but they they
obviously
pulled through this and then you have
the 2007 season and that's where things
really got difficult
because
they had just won their fifth super bowl
together
and i think that tom wanted to
be treated a little bit differently than
he had during you know
his previous unprecedented run so then
let's get just dive into that here uh
why would belichick not because i saw
bill you know
up close and personal at the nfl 100
all-time team show again and that's the
closest i've ever most i've ever been
around the man um in in one sitting for
a day and a half and he was fully uh um
you know open about his time with
belichick i mean with parcells and
everywhere he's been and
admitting that you treat players
differently at a certain level and how
you know parcells once told him you know
after he re told bill
that uh he that lawrence taylor was late
to a meeting and he told parcells this
and parcells response was why'd you
start it without him
so you know why would belichick never
make these changes or would he say
uh even if maybe on background you know
hey i did make a lot of stuff we did do
a lot of stuff for tom i did make a lot
of exceptions for tom like where's
what's the disconnect if there is one at
all on that side definitely a disconnect
and actually have a great anecdote um
in the book of about bill belichick eric
mangini in thai law were were bill
belichick gives eric mangini that same
speech that parcells gave
um belichick back in the day
um
but
you know look i mean
i i wrote a lot about this at the time
but they they're coming off a fifth
super bowl and tom decided to branch out
he had his tb 12 book he did the tom
versus time documentary for the first
time ever he really stepped out of just
being an employee of the patriots
and really tried to promote something
else that was really strictly about him
and not the team now
one could argue that he was always
treated differently you know bill
belichick's come out and said publicly
that every decision they made for 20
years was
designed to be what's best for tom brady
so it's clear that and you know tom
brady had a window you know a direct
line to the owner he could go to you
know whenever he wanted to vent or get
something off of his chest and a lot of
the coaches actually felt like that
craft
not intentionally but by trying to hear
brady out craft obviously is trying to
keep this this band together as long as
he could the crap made the relationship
harder between brady and belichick
because it it sort of almost
inadvertently painted belichick is more
of the bad guy in the building but that
said you know look you've bill belichick
at that time
really invested in jimmy garoppolo and
wanting garoppolo you know to to take
over for brady at some point and for
bill's legacy to be kind of extending
the winning beyond whoever's playing
quarterback
and then in the middle of it you have
alex guerrero who he mentioned it
earlier
and he was becoming his advice was
becoming a problem in the building
obviously tom was evangelical about the
tb12 methods
and it was at odds a lot of the time
with the patriots doctors and so a lot
of players felt conflicted because
they're like who do we go to do we go to
the most powerful players guy do we go
to the team doctors like what do we do
here
and then
you know bill belichick ends up
banning alex guerrero
um in the middle you know that that
story breaks in the middle of the season
and you know at one point brady said i i
don't want to play for bill anymore and
you know all of these things had just
sort of
colluded and and sort of
were set on fire at the exact moment
during that season and now you look at
look at brady skip the offseason program
although all the voluntary workouts that
next off season only nfl quarterback to
do that seth wickersham espn senior
writer and of course the author of it's
better to be here on the rich eisen show
i haven't gotten deep into the book yet
do you cover the garoppolo stuff did
brady want him out like did did he did
all those rumors what did you discover
about the
that moment because clearly you know it
is also informing what's going on in
green bay right and what aaron rodgers
might be trying to
to pull off for a lack of a better
phrase and then the fact that brady now
goes to tampa and wins and has a
situation that that he wanted in new
england but didn't get and that rogers
is trying to attempt apparently in green
bay i mean this is it's not just the
past it's also present in its prologue
to what we're seeing maybe in the future
there's a lot going on here what did you
discover about the garoppolo stuff well
i mean look bill was invested in
garoppolo and you know he has a lot of
pride we all know that and you know
whenever he walks away from the patriots
he wants to walk away
with that team set up long-term and
especially a quarterback that's the most
vital piece and so he had drafted
garoppolo and and you know i think at a
lot of points
might have preferred to turn to him
but brady played well craft was clearly
in brady's corner and you know he ends
up shipping um garoppolo to san
francisco you know right before the
trade deadline for a second round pick
i and others reported that that craft
essentially made it clear that he needed
to trade um garoppolo and that brady was
you know their their their present and
their future
um craft pushed back at that
and denied that but
it would that he was just another thing
and you know i i think that brady knew
that bill was invested in garoppolo and
even that became another
you know contentious point like what do
i gotta do here you know like do you
what do we gotta do together we've won
five super bowls and so
i think that jimmy garoppolo was
definitely you know part of that
conflict during that season and if you
fast forward and you talk about what's
happening now
brady's not just a quarterback in tampa
bay alex guerrero you know banned from
the team playing in the sideline and a
lot of the building in new england has
his own office in tampa bay and got a
super bowl ring
you know what tom brady is treated as a
different person he's almost the
quarterback and a pseudo executive and
the offensive coordinator in a lot of
ways and
at the end of his run in new england he
wanted a little bit more say over
personnel he wanted a little bit more
say over game planning he told joe
montana you know look i give my opinion
they listen and then they go do their
own thing
and i think that all of that
stuff it had just run its course by the
end and he was ready to go so do we
again um do we know did brady basically
say to craft he's got to go and look the
bottom line is what a decision that may
that that was with the ultimate of
respect to belichick and garoppolo i
mean
the lion's share of the you know they
they got they got three more out of it
you know i think yeah we talked about
that
did craft say to or did bernie say to
craft about yeah
right yeah no i mean tom wanted to be
there and he wanted an extension and he
did you know he he would love to not
have jimmy nipping at his heels but tom
brady doesn't have the the the power to
order a trade i know that when i did a
story in 2018
about the dynamics in the building a lot
of people
somehow took away that brady had sort of
ordered this trade or tried to force it
i i never reported that i never heard it
so but you know i i think brady felt
like look we've won five super bowls
together i want to play until i'm 45
years old
why can't we just fix this up the owner
wants him to be toys 45 years old it was
bill who had reservations about it and
um
and
i i just i always go back to the end of
that falcons you know
super bowl when they beat the falcons
if they had just signed tom brady to a
five-year deal right then
so much of the acrimony that transpired
over the next couple years would have
been averted
so i guess that that's a question um you
know for the moment to put a point on it
seth wikishim his book it's better to be
feared coming out october 12th it's
must-have must read certainly for any
football fan of the last say quarter
century uh right here on the rich eisen
show so um you know when you watch the
last dance you're just sitting there
just shaking your head like how the hell
did this happen how in the world did
they allow it to stop
and what could have been done to stop
the train with us now 20 years later
seeing
what uh how tough it is and all of that
could anything have changed like what
what what what could have changed the
dynamic certainly
we're we're going to be talking about it
so much between now and sunday night as
well with the
with the reunion um
could anything have changed was it
literally a five-year deal or would that
have been would that have changed the
dynamic i think all these guys would
have gotten on each other's nerves and
but
i think that they
stayed together
because
they knew for as long as they did
because they knew that
you know they needed to to accomplish
what they wanted this was their best
chance to win
um
that said again tom brady has wanted has
made it very clear for a long time
that he was going to play until he was
in his 40s and then 45 and who knows
maybe it's beyond now
and the patriots just wouldn't commit to
it you know bill belichick thought that
tom brady was near the end
and in april of 2019
um you know that's a couple months after
you had seen them together and they had
a great day together um at the studio
for that nfl one hundred on special a
special that bill belichick wanted me
for um
the contract negotiations did not go
well and tom brady nearly left camp
because he was so frustrated about it in
protest
and there was a moment
that tommy curran noticed of nbc sports
boston at practice where
um a receiver lined up at a wrong in the
wrong spot and brady didn't correct him
he just stared at the coaches and his
body language was very clear
you guys want to run this team go ahead
and
brady ends up signing
an extension in that training camp
that's billed as a two-year extension
and for a second we're thinking oh they
got it done brady will be in new england
until he's 45 but then we looked at it
it was really just a raise with an out
at the end of the year and right then
tom brady knew that it was his last year
in new england and he and his wife
two days after that contract was
announced
it was announced that they put their
home up for sale
and so what uh have i not asked you
about that wasn't in the article that
came out on espn.com yesterday i know
and you're laughing because it's
probably about 98 of the book that
wasn't put into this uh article but you
do you have something that might be of
interest to the fans that has yet to be
revealed i mean there's a lot of things
but
i think that look there's there's
certain elements of it that are a little
bit easier to talk about because um you
know there might be a little buzz worthy
or whatever but i really tried
as best i could i know i repeated this
earlier but i really tried to get inside
the key moments that made these men
great
like tom brady back in michigan i've got
a bunch of new stuff um especially about
his relationship with his counselor greg
hardin i don't know if you've ever met
greg
and but he was his counselor at michigan
and
um
he had a really it is he's become a
confidant throughout brady's career but
during the the worst times in brady's
career at michigan
he would respond very interestingly to
tom
um
time when when tom would come in and
he'd be whining about
where he was buried on the depth chart
that he was only getting three reps or
whatever was hard would kind of laugh at
him
and the night that brady was going to
transfer to cal he told coach carr that
he was probably leaving he goes to see
greg hardin
he says you know i think i'm
transferring
and craig harden starts laughing at him
like he doesn't say hey tom please stay
don't give up you're better than this he
starts laughing and he says
you haven't done
you know bleep here anyway
no one's going to care if you leave you
want to leave
go ahead
and you know things that moments like
that really ignited brady's competitive
juices i've got another moment later on
one of the the themes i read about the
book is
you know brady's acclimation to this
unbelievable fame and how quickly it
arrived and how he was
having to process it on the fly
and at one point two thousand three
brady's whining to greg hart on the
phone about how he can't go to the
grocery store he can't get gas he can't
do this everyone's following me
and again you know greg harden his
counselor just starts laughing at him
and he's like tom you're saying you want
to be the best but you don't want to
deal with these other things like
you were he said you're the hot cookie
right now you have a chance to change a
kid's life just by picking up the phone
and talking to him for five minutes
so this isn't gonna last forever so take
advantage of this as it turns out tom's
been a hot cookie for 20 years he sure
has i mean his name is now synonymous
with winning like lombardi seriously
i mean his last name is now synonymous
with winning in a way like you know be
like brady
jordan lombardi
that's literally what he has turned
himself into and he can still continue
to do it and what an incredible reunion
that we're going to see this weekend
what what do you think happens i mean
the game before the game on the field i
mean did brady and belichick share a
moment craft they play a video for him
uh they're going to stop the game when
he breaks breezes all-time passing
record what do you think based on all
your reporting and knowing all the the
politics and the emotions and the hard
feelings and things like that yeah even
if the feelings are still hard i i would
bet that you know they're gonna hug
before the game i bet there's a video
tribute remember when peyton manning
came back to indianapolis as a denver
bronco they played this video tribute he
started tearing up during warm-ups
and you know the the best way to get in
tom's to shake him off of his resolute
focus is to
you know do something unexpected and you
know if you kind of appeal to him
emotionally he's remembered about all
reminded about all the good times there
you wonder if like that might give new
england a little bit of an edge dude so
you're saying if they play a video it's
not because it's heartfelt because it's
gamesmanship is that literally what you
just said seth workership you do you not
know these men
have we learned nothing you know what
are the things i write about in the book
yeah one of the things i write about the
book is how bill kind of breaks these
other really proud men and coaches you
know he just he prepares so meticulously
and he sees the game so globally that
there are moments that he
has in games and decisions that he makes
that end up haunting proud men for the
rest of their lives i mean the the best
one obviously is what he did to mike
martin the super bowl when they you know
destroyed marshall falcon completely
took my part out of his rhythm and mike
shanahan was another one in in 2003
there was a monday night game where the
patriots were trailing and they took an
intentional safety
thinking that they'd surrender the point
and hoping they'd gain some field
position and give brady a chance to win
it new england ends up winning it
and tom brady uh mike shanahan and bill
belichick
friend since the eighties
and you know competitive friends and
with a huge amount of respect for each
other in that game really haunted mike
shanahan even in his respect for bill
belichick grew um
fast forward a couple years two thousand
seven spygate breaks
everyone's talking about it roger
goodell the commissioner is trying to
learn as much as he can about this
illegal videotaping practice and how
much of an advantage it is in games
he calls coaches around the league and
they're just burying belichick they're
just saying you gotta take it to this
guy it was the peak of piousness
and then he called mike shanahan who at
the time you know would want to super
bowls and was
incredibly well respected coach
and i laugh every time i i think about
this he tells roger goodell
i wish i had thought of doing this
and he was disappointed in himself
that he didn't think of cheating the way
that bill belichick was cheating and it
was a real window into how the best of
the best think at this level
all right some quick hitters before we
go you mentioned how you know belichick
took march out and marshall faulk out
they think they were videotaped all week
and in the red zone i mean i've spoken
to tons of rams who won't really you
know say it publicly all that much
because it it doesn't really you know uh
suit uh somebody who's lost to say we
lost because we got cheated against but
what'd you uncover about that in this
book well i mean
there's there's no evidence that that
happened um but it doesn't mean that
people don't believe it and you know
that's one of those things that they've
had to deal with for all of those years
obviously the boston herald reported
that they take the walk through later
had to retract that report but
um
you know i i reported with don banana
years ago
about the meeting where nfl executives
came to new england and they viewed the
videos that ernie adams and bill
belichick had
of illegal signals and illegal
recordings
and jeff past the nfl general counsel
ended up destroying the tapes by
stomping on them in the room and then he
left them in the room
for robin glazer who is the patriots uh
lawyer to clean up the mess i mean the
acrimony that began with spy gate
between the patriots and the nfl
it really can't be discounted and
obviously a lot of those themes
came into effect if you know when
deflategate came around years later and
then you know the whole spygate thing
coming from mangini uh going to the jets
and and saying about hey this is what
they do and then they stopped them
cold when they were trying to do it
against the jets well they nearly fought
like literally
eric didn't blow the whistle he told the
patriots to stop doing it he he used
some colorful language that again you
can read but we can't repeat but he was
basically like i know you guys do this
knock it off
and they refuse to do it and it was the
jets jets upper management that
blew the whistle on it it wasn't eric
and but of course eric ended up being
the fall guy ever because of his
relationship with bill
and because of how toxic things had
gotten when eric left to go to the jets
so fast forward that was in september of
oh seven fast forward to the spring of
two thousand eight at the league
meetings there's a dinner for coaches
afterwards everyone's kind of mingling
around and julie mangini eric's wife
ends up rubbing elbows with belichick
and she says hi to him and she kind of
tries to
be friendly remember belichick read a
poem at their wedding
um
try to be friendly to ease this tension
and bill blew her off
she goes back until she was upset about
this she told eric what happened and he
goes charging across the room at bill
and two head coaches had to hold him
back because otherwise i thought he was
going to take a swing at him and he
yelled
something that bill that again you know
we can't say on the radio
last one for you
with bill o'brien in houston and some of
the maneuvers he was making with the
more power that he got was such a head
scratcher including you know what he did
obviously with deandre hopkins and then
uh
it's revealed in your book uh just to uh
i guess paraphrase what was written in
the espn.com article bill o'brien told a
colleague he tried to get fired as the
coach of the texans because he thought
he might be able to succeed belichick
can we put these two together as an
explanation as to why so much of the
bizarre moves that were being made by
bill o'brien was being made by bill
o'brien yeah i don't know i mean build a
temperamental guy on billy o'brien but
yeah i mean
look at 2007 season the craft didn't
know if bill was gonna
want to be there and for if so for how
long you know there's some a lot of
um
you know reporting that came out after
the fact that you know maybe bill didn't
wanna be there anymore and
you know brady was ready to play for
another coach and he thought one night
he and crafter talking and again this is
kind of a fanciful
plan but they were just kind of
spitballing and you know
what if josh mcdaniels left to be a head
coach which he was expected to do at the
time maybe we could hire you know billy
o'brien to come back and maybe he could
succeed belichick and you know look this
was all never going to happen
but
you know word got back to billy o'brien
about it and he was obviously in a huge
power struggle you know later on and
winning that power struggle in houston
he later joked to someone that you know
yeah i was trying to get fired because
he knew that there was a golden
parachute i see so that the trying to
get fired was prior to the power that he
actually accrued is what you're saying
thank you seth wickersham i appreciate
it um again when the book comes out um
look for my call i'll have you back on
and talk about so much of the other
stuff i'll have read the entire thing
cover to cover by then congratulations
on this congrats thank you it's just so
terrific that's seth workershim right
here on the rich eisen show and i thank
him thank you seth for
being our your first stop
literally could have gone on the two
hours
for real
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here